with coronavirus now spreading from
person to person within the UK health
officials are looking at a menu of
options to delay the worst of the
outbreak including social distancing
that's minimizing the contact between
people
moderate restrictions could include
working from home and cancelling events
with big crowds such as football games
and concerts more extreme measures could
include quarantine in towns or stopping
public transport just as the authorities
did in the Chinese province of Hubei so
what impact would they have well Sky
News has commissioned exclusive research
from the same team at Lancaster
University that's helping the government
plan its strategy this is the rise and
fall of cases that we might expect over
the next few months with no action but
imposing moderate restrictions on social
contact for four weeks could delay the
epidemic to the summer and reduce the
peak by 25 percent easing the load on
the NHS imposing the same restrictions
for longer eight weeks would reduce the
peak even more by 50% with cases tailing
off just as the autumn sets in an even
bigger benefit for the Health Service
finally the academics looked at the more
extreme approach of sealing off cities
over eight weeks and the effect was
dramatic at first reducing the peak by
80 percent
but once the restrictions were lifted
the computer model suggests there would
be a second wave of cases and a higher
peak just at the start of the winter flu
season it's a warning to public health
England Sun restriction on social
contact would help the NHS cope with
peak demand but too much and it simply
shunts the epidemic into next winter
when hospitals will be stretched to
capacity dealing with other illnesses
you